maintaining flow is similar to catching
a occurrence in the ocean once you're in
it you seem to be gliding with the flow
rather than always trying to hold on to
it it's something that just comes to you
and you stay with it
[Music]
flow is when a person is in a highly
focused mental state where nothing else
seems to matter it occurs when you're
perceived skill level and the challenge
at hand are equal and your is in control
of your minds and body as you can be
when I experience flow I just feel
really really focused and everything
seems to work for me
you just feel confident and everything
you do there's no negative thoughts
coming in you just feel like you can
perform to your best each time the key
aspects of flow are being able to
perform a task seemingly automatically
having absolute concentration on the
task at hand maintaining a sense of
control over the performance and a loss
of self-consciousness
[Music]
[Music]
then tennis there can be tons of things
that can distract you when it comes to
sport many athletes focus on the outcome
of the game the match or the race the
desire to win or to become distracted by
how they played in the last point when
athletes dwell in these egocentric
thoughts will often see them start to
lose focus and their performance starts
to deteriorate the most difficult thing
about seeing a flaw is the external
things your opponent as obviously can be
one of the most distracting things and
just to isolate yourself sometimes from
your opponent and simply focus on what
you're doing and really helps for a more
focused and little display although
being in the states of flow is something
that's usually associated with high
level athletes it's something that
potentially anyone is able to achieve
from playing an instrument to a surgeon
carrying a complex operation but what
can you do to give yourself the best
possible chance of achieving a state of
flow here are my tips to help increase
the probability of flaw in your everyday
life always be praising sports
psychologist Barbara Taylor highlighted
the importance of letting go of memories
of shots good or bad and focus on the
here and now as it really helps you
focus in the process and what you are
specifically doing at that moment in
time this can be achieved through
setting mastery orientated goals but you
can recite to yourself at times
throughout the performance give yourself
immediate feedback a key characteristic
of floors immediate feedback this can be
prevented by teammates coaches or
yourself as you complete the activity
when possible trying to figure out what
you're doing well and why as well as
what you could be doing better and hope
this will make you an active learner and
aid the development of future goals and
targets necessary to achieve your
desired outcome be a better practitioner
of your skills not a goal chaser this
feedback could be based on your preset
mastery orientates goals
am i achieving these or not what can I
do to achieve this doing this as quickly
as possible will help you effectively
move on from situations and focus on the
present
challenge yourself if the task is too
easy then focus is extremely difficult
to achieve and it may become tedious if
the task is too difficult you may feel
anxious about whether or not you can
meet the demands make sure you always
set yourself goals that match your skill
level but also challenge it when you
achieve these goals set yourself more
challenging targets in order to remain
and flow I crash they find flow quite
easy to remain but hard to find but once
you find it you're in the zone as it
says you just you just flow through the
match thanks for watching don't forget
to subscribe and click the bail to
receive notifications for new videos see
you again soon